y nos preguntan cuál es el valor del
término 100 de esta sucesión 15 93 y
menos 3 puntitos es decir es una
sucesión infinita bueno lo primero que
se me va a ocurrir es escribir los
términos y el valor de cada uno de estos
términos esto para que veamos claramente
quién es el término y quién es el valor
del término el primer término es 15 por
lo tanto el término 1
su valor es 15 en el término 2 su valor
es 9 el término 3
su valor es 3 y para finalizar pues
vamos a ver qué pasa con el término 4 el
término 4 tiene como valor menos 3 y la
verdad estaría muy bien encontrar una
expresión que medirá el valor de
cualquier término es decir encontrar una
expresión tal que si nosotros cambiamos
la n nos dé el valor que queremos
encontrar en este caso estamos buscando
el valor del término 100 y si
encontramos esta expresión o esta
fórmula ya podríamos encontrar su valor
que estamos buscando y bueno lo primero
que se me ocurre ver es cuánto hay de
diferencia entre cada uno de estos
de 15 a 9 bajamos 6 unidades de 9 a 3
bajamos también 6 unidades y de 13 menos
3 a ver 3 para 0 son 3 unidades y 0 para
menos 3 también son 3 unidades por lo
tanto en total bajamos 6 unidades es
decir que esta es una sucesión
aritmética recuerden que una asociación
aritmética es cuando bajamos siempre la
misma cantidad o subimos siempre la
misma cantidad en este caso estamos
decreciendo es una sucesión que está
decreciendo de 6 en 6 y perfecto porque
una sucesión aritmética tiene una
expresión para encontrar cualquier valor
de cualquier término super bien ya lo
hicimos en este caso nos piden el
término 100 pero se imaginan si vamos
restando de seis en seis en seis en seis
hasta llegar al término 100 va a ser
tremendo mejor vamos a buscar la
formulita para encontrar este término
100 y bueno aunque ya lo hemos visto en
los vídeos pasados me gustaría
recordarles un poco como construyamos
esta forma lista primero ponemos la
cantidad
inicial que es 15 y después nos damos
cuenta que en el primer valor no hicimos
nada tenemos al 15 ya esto le quitamos 0
veces que bajamos 6 unidades mientras
que en el segundo término tenemos 15 mi
cantidad inicial pero esta vez vamos a
bajar una vez 6 por lo tanto va a ser
menos 1 por 6 en el caso del tercer
término tenemos otra vez la cantidad
inicial solamente que la diferencia es
que vamos a bajar 2 veces 6 por lo tanto
tengo menos 2 por 6 menos 2 por 6 porque
hemos bajado 2 veces 6 es decir hemos
bajado menos 2 unidades y ahora en el
cuarto término tengo que también es 15
pero en esta ocasión he bajado 3 veces 6
unidades por lo tanto tengo 15 menos 3
por 6 perfecto y después nos dimos
cuenta que realmente lo que estábamos
haciendo era tener n menos uno
multiplicado por la cantidad que
bajábamos por ejemplo aquí en el término
4 tenemos 3 aquí el término 3 tenemos 2
aquí en el término 2 tenemos 1 en el
término 1 tenemos cero es decir cuando
nosotros teníamos el término n lo que
hacíamos era
15 - y aquí le bajamos 1 a n si de aquí
es 4 bajamos a 3 x 3 bajamos a 2 si aquí
es 2 bajamos a 1 si tenemos n entonces
vamos a bajarle una unidad es decir que
si tenemos en él cuando le bajemos una
unidad me va a quedar en menos uno por
lo tanto a 15 hay que quitarle n menos 1
y esto multiplicado por seis porque cada
vez que bajábamos al siguiente término
le bajábamos seis unidades esto es para
el término n y esto está perfecto porque
ya encontramos la fórmula para cualquier
término para el término n en dado caso
que nos pidan el 100 que es lo que nos
preguntan pues hay que poner 15 ya 15
hay que restarle 99 por 6 lo único que
estoy haciendo es seguir utilizando esta
fórmula que acabo de encontrar esta
expresión para encontrar el término en
él pero sustituido en el término 100 a
ver cuántos noventa y nueve por seis
regresemos a las tablas de primaria a 99
lo voy a multiplicar por 6 y bueno esto
hasta lo podríamos hacer en la mente
porque es lo mismo que 6
100 que 606 es decir 594 pero de todas
maneras si lo quieres hacer por el
método tradicional vamos a hacerlo con
calma 9 por 654 ponemos el 4 y llevamos
5 9 por 6 54 exacto + 5 59 594 entonces
de todo esto es 594 a quien se hay que
quitarle 594 y cómo hacemos eso vamos a
escribirlo acá
15 - 594 a 15 le tengo que quitar 594
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 594
menos 15 con un signo negativo
dicho de otra manera lo que estoy
haciendo es factor izando al menos es
decir menos que multiplica a 594 menos
15 date cuenta que estas dos expresiones
son lo mismo
- por 594 me quedan menos 594 y menos
por menos 15 me da más 15 15 positivo la
única diferencia es que 594 menos 15 ya
es muy sencillo de realizar aver 594 le
quitamos 15 pues es lo mismo que 594 le
quitamos 10 es decir 500
y 4 y después le quitamos 5 584 5 579 o
sea que la diferencia de estos 500 79
pero tenemos un signo menos aquí
entonces hay que agregarle el signo
menos y ya está
ya con eso encontramos el resultado de
este problema mi valor del término 100
es menos 579